huge colleges gone off wolf rebellion
and revolution for more than a decade
I've been outside britain reporting on
some of the big events shaping lives and
views inside back in Britain also known
as the United Kingdom I haven't lived
here since 2005 and I want to find out
just how much has changed over the past
twelve years
[Music]
at the post of the middle make a
brandish making the mouth I feel that I
am British because I was born here
some dead definitely embrace but you
know it doesn't to me doesn't mean
anything Jasmine can you get a bit
closer to curing Slava right why doesn't
it mean anything he'll let them don't
from letdown necessarily for like that
there's no there's no up every minute I
openly hope and see any sort of
progression
I saw a niche in the market there was no
agency fazer models so I just decided to
kind of open up an agency they were kind
of geared towards what towards their
Asian models the ethos I can bring to
the company in terms of hiring staff in
terms of getting models and talent out
there of ethnic minorities would be
beneficial because no one else's
business he's not doing it Marcus is
giving me an insight into a different
side of Britain and one that isn't just
one as young people do you identify with
anyone anything any country any passport
we would define ourselves to be British
we were born here and culturally we know
where we come from where our family
comes from background but if somebody
says where are you from like yeah I'm
from Britain hopefully like it'll get
better I think you know with the
internet and stuff like that I think
people coming a bit more where you can
raise awareness they were different
not every brown person is the
stereotypical person you think they are
because we can see everything I feel
less British because I just I can see
the whole world and I feel like for
human more than British mesons have you
felt um included do in anything in this
society no not really
which is why I started my own company
which is why I've started a company
that's so diverse as well because I
don't feel
included in that and is good to kind of
do my own thing and feel included within
wondering really little bit of
foundation the models who are part of
his beim agency feel the same need a lot
of the asian magazines only use European
girls and I remember going to a number
of castings and being told I was too
dark I think it is something even from a
young age that always affected me or
made me think that I'd never really be
beautiful because I have darker skin how
much of a change was brexit for you I
felt a little bit rejected actually if
right if I'm totally honest because I
felt like wife I'm so British I feel
really fresh like I've I'm very proud of
being British and that all of a sudden
now like the fact that we have voted
breaks it makes me feel like maybe we're
not wanted in a country that I was born
and raised in and that my mom and dad
have all sort of worked hard to be in so
I think that changed my outlook on
people in general the models and Marcus
all have stories of rejection at job
interviews if you're a white employer
you may just want to employ the person
who's white you know that's why I think
I think it's just a reflex thing I don't
think it's racist per se I think it's
more kind of well it's not overt racism
no it's kind of a little bit yes can you
be a little bit racist like a little bit
pregnant I mean I think you can be
ignorant and then there's definitely
ignorant involved and I think people
feel safer stronger to use button they
feel safer when around their own people
which isn't good
Marcus was so affected by the London
riots of 2011 he made a film based
around them
[Music]
the inequality is caused by race was a
central theme
[Music]
like a war zone as mom Nigel Farage has
played on things like this to get his
point across and to get himself that
notoriety there's comedy whoa do you see
the two incidences being linked yes in
terms of the brexit vote and the London
riots
yes I do but if you live in the middle
of nowhere and you're watching this
you're thinking this is either black
people or these are people from Europe
doing causing these riots you're going
to feel it instantly think to yourself I
don't want these people in my country I
want to vote tear them out my country so
I think this definitely helps people who
say that we shouldn't be in the country
it definitely helps even though when you
look at the footage there are sure
different races writing a lot of
commercial and fashion especially
fashion work they weren't getting
primarily because of the race you can
see they look they look amazing what I'm
doing here is like a drop and drop in
the ocean is something that's not enough
do you feel that things may have taken a
few steps backwards with the physical
changes here
um yeah definitely
there's going to be more kind of
intrinsic sort of Union from white white
privileged people and I think that it
will affect Asians and blacks and
getting jobs in the UK in modeling in
fashion in film which is where I work as
well and just the society in general